[Music]
just 60 miles from washington dc is one
of america's most celebrated small towns
harpers ferry
situated between the beautiful potomac
and shenandoah rivers is the town's inn
my wife anna and i bought the end for my
mom back in 2007.
we want it to be a good investment but
we also bought more with our hearts than
our heads i think it's the type of woman
who's happiest when she's working so we
figured this would be a good place for
her to work and enjoy
the seasonal life that she's in
i'm a grandmother so it's kind of
grandmother's house
and i'm here mainly because i've retired
from teaching i love historical
properties and decided that being an
innkeeper would be a fun thing for the
rest of my life
[Music]
the town's inn is probably kind of like
a circus karen's the ringleader and you
never know what's gonna happen next
working for karen is interesting it's
frustrating she's pretty set in her ways
and it's her way or the highway
i think what makes someone a good mom
isn't necessarily what makes someone a
good boss or a good business owner karen
as a business woman she don't have no
experience
and it's awful
karen treats this place as both her
business and her home but more her home
i mean her bedroom was in her office you
know she'd sleep right there pretty much
in the dining room
i have asked karen is this your home or
restaurant or is it an end you can't
have it all three ways inspect to make
money
parents absolutely a hoarder karen
hoards her clothes old shoes books
baskets don't even get me started on
those damn baskets there's baskets
everywhere you could open a closet and
hotel room and see a pile of baskets you
could walk in our server area open the
fridge and i bet there'd be a basket
there because they're literally
everywhere
[Music]
karen's in denial of what's wrong she
needs to separate herself from this
place or things aren't going to change
we are suffering we are in debt the
customers are going away
while we don't want to sell the towns in
i think we're certainly at a crossroads
of just saying is this becoming
overwhelming for my mom you know she's
not getting any younger and it's just it
could be a potential train wreck
so if the ship is sinking then we want
to make sure we get our mom off of the
boat before it sinks
[Music]
wow look at this place gorgeous
fresh food
wow
nice to see they're in townsend karen
good to see you i'm glad you're here
gorgeous little town does it remind you
of yours isn't it kind of the quaints we
have a movie set i mean it's just
literally that many times is it ready
yeah wow okay i'll just have a quick
look around and uh yeah i'll follow you
okay um
what's all this out here what is that oh
that's just watering the plants yeah and
we get a lot of hikers and it rains here
sometimes what is this who knows it in
here a long time but it's like freddy
krueger's hat who who's is this it's
just there for anybody that wants to
borrow oh i see and does anyone borrow
that
they haven't yet
interesting
another one as well and what
are these things
they're oh they're for sale yeah see
summery heads how much are these three
three to three to twenty three pennies
and this is how much
maybe not more whatever you wanna offer
we're very flexible i'm not too sure if
it's my style and uh oh that's dusty
that's a pretty special one um why is it
so special because it's
full of dust yeah west virginia and this
is almost heaven how much does that work
it's whatever you offer are these
second-hand
no not that some things are but not that
is your business are you selling money
are you are you busy no we don't really
sell a lot of hats i see mm-hmm
well hello you got customers in already
hello this is my friend sarah sarah oh
nice to meet you thank you good to see
you
join us for lunch today are you i have
no idea i'm up to whatever i'm here i do
um
she's just a family friend
okay right so you're not a customer i'm
so sorry right not a customer is this a
convenience store or this is the dining
room
wow i mean it's very claustrophobic in
here there's bits and bobs of everything
those um freaky dolls what are they for
they are sort of uh souvenirs are you
selling laws we do
wow but dusty a lot of people who come
here have children they're looking for
something to take back what about this
one here collector's choice how much is
this one i think 25.
jesus they're dusting i didn't know they
were for sale you didn't know they're
for sale
how much does this room make a month um
i can't give you an exact figure because
it required the purchases in with the
restaurant sales yeah that i would say
in 15 of sales 15
who drinks all this cider and no
actually we use that in the restaurant
jeez
well we sell a lot of it it's good in
the summer june july and august
now my daughter made those right what
are they they're little hats for little
children it's full of dust and hair and
what's this hot pads handmade hot pads
is that 60
who buys this people with children
i hope people with children
that's full of dust inside
well you have to wash it before you use
it
look
um what's this this is sarah's journal
so she keeps a journal yeah wow
so it's uh it's almost like a novel it
is and she puts sermon notes and
telephone numbers and prices and she
calls it her brain a public bathroom
decorate with baskets
yeah she decorated the baskets up in my
washroom oh
oh dear okay
wow so um all right what's that there
that is a bottle holder you can put like
a water bottle in it so it does appeal
right i thought it was a jock strap
you know it couldn't it looks like a
joke
i hadn't thought of that but you got a
point
what's that down yes that's our bread
and then behind that is the closet where
our potatoes are kept but are the are
the loaves for sale too
if someone asks for them and hikers do
sometime but normally it's um it's just
for the breakfast we have toast are you
expecting a lot of people that's how
much we go through in a few days believe
it or not really unfortunately out of
date as well we couldn't are you serious
second of november
okay you're right today's the sixth oh
that's very embarrassing yeah let's go
to my uh my room
what is that oh these are my famous
baskets
yeah i love baskets and i collect them
beautiful baskets for sale prices vary
from one to thirty dollars stop it
thirty dollars
some of them are very unique you're
telling me that families come in here
and they go for a hike and they buy
these baskets on the way
to the mountains
stop
this one's full of bugs i guess i
wouldn't buy that one would you twelve
dollars
and that's with the cockroaches we don't
charge extra
wow that was 12.99 it's reduced down to
five dollars
oh bugs in there as well bloody hell
did you get them as gifts and then
resell them
uh no i just buy them when i find them
places
the hell is that it's an easter basket
ah that's an easter basket [ __ ] it now
poor bunny and how much is that one
dollar yeah
well can you go any lower
no huh we don't deal in cents ah yeah
yeah karen it's starting to scare me
seriously you are a basket case that's a
good point honestly there's dust
everywhere up here as well
when was the last time this place was
dusted
uh theoretically every day every oh
every day yeah this is my room named
after the potato flavor
wow
bloody hell
oh dear and this is it
wow
uh wow
we have five rooms this one is 130. oh
oh [ __ ]
what
what happened there
you're taller than i am see he just lays
up there on the on top of the
no see there you go the pole is too
short my darling look so
sorry
look that's that
and this has been here since 2007 and
it's never falling down already
flip it now okay oh [ __ ] okay let's
leave them there for now let's get some
light in here
okay i'm gonna i'm packing yeah that's
private what do you mean it's private
this is my bedroom uh well but this is
off-limits it's got a lock on it it's
like a storage closet
but if i'm paying for the room i'd like
to get into my wardrobe you're not
paying for that you're paying for
everything else
but then really
we've got these little things you can
put your suitcase on but what's in here
my clothes
your clothes
seriously seriously it's very
inconvenient when there are people here
and i can't get to my clothes but i live
with it
um i want to hang my clothes in my
wardrobe 1840 we we use hooks hooks
why don't you get me key to open this i
need to hang my uh my jackets um you'll
just have to use a hook
um once again this is a rental you're
renting me a room i'm here to help you
and i'd like to use my wardrobe
can i have a look inside then please
because i'm just worried in case you put
somebody in there
[Music]
there you go
these are all your clothes
literally are
that's it that's it well there's a few
jackets in the wardrobe upstairs so you
have another right above us is another
room and another room that you rent out
with a padlock on
come on you're paying 130 for the
owner's clothes to stay in the wardrobe
that's a first for me congratulations i
feel really uncomfortable about having
my wardrobe full of all your clothes
i can cover it up but it stays locked so
you can just ignore it can i just have
half of this then do you mind
oh okay
shelley
shelly
how much [ __ ] can one
the water
gordon wanted uh you to bring some of
those clothes and things down just put
them in my office okay
oh hi oh my do you see karen wearing
this stuff no kevin wears about two
outfits what do you mean she wears two
outfits
i've never seen her in anything other
than what she's wearing and denim and
bait
it's like garments from the civil war
and do you ever go through this stuff
karen do you ever think wow i'll change
color today maybe a bright color with
red or seasonally seasonally mm-hmm so
this is your fall look now this is this
is how we head into wintertime in summer
it's usually denim or a beige okay so no
no white after labor day then
never never
okay thank you thank you no problem
wow this is crazy i mean i've never met
such a basket case like this in all my
life i mean the place is cluttered and
it's almost like her belongings are
everywhere you turn left or right
there's either a basket or an item of
cara's clothing why is that
pillowcases
what's in here
looks like a blanket
more baskets
of course
my room is cluttered
and here look at that in there
oh my god
look at all this stuff
[ __ ]
how could you fit all that in there that
is um
definitely took skill where is she
downstairs in the background i could ask
her to come up with me please this is
insane karen
yes
karen yes
look at all this stuff shoes handbags
scarves just smell them
it smells like
my shoes
but they stink my darling they reek you
can't let me spell your shoes
they smell like
like my shoes yeah they shouldn't be in
my room
well like i said in my mind you went at
everything except
this wardrobe which i wanted to tell me
that when you took my money
you didn't ask ah
and what about these
those are extra sets of linens yeah but
why do i want all them and leave my bed
now you don't need to be under the bed
do you
but we'll get this out for you and i'll
just put it downstairs
unbelievable
i just want to sleep in a room that's
not clustered
oh
watch your steps
i have never experienced a place like
this before
dolls
hats baskets full of bugs a wardrobe
full of the owner's clothes to be honest
i'm frightened about the meal i'm about
to eat
what's that
what is that that looks like
something that can i buy this absolutely
chopsticks why would you go hiking with
a [ __ ] pair of chopsticks and a
little wooden spoon i'll take that you
can add it to my tab
brenda i'm seating um gordon yes ma'am
right here
i'm gonna start you with an ice water
okay
okay
and brenda's gonna be how often
once an hour at least any chance i can
go through the hotel
no i wouldn't think so now
[Music]
town's inn of harpers ferry almost
heaven it's certainly not my room that's
for sure
hey how you doing however all right
um first name is
le mans good to see you what do you do a
little bit everything big questions
where do you store your clothes do i
have any of your clothes in my room no
no no third no because we're the same
size oh no
shoes under the bed i promise no toys
under the bench never mind promise me i
promise excellence
yes sir good to see you nice meeting you
light-wise
all right
are you ready
nice to see how have you been here two
years two years how's it going it's a
little frustrating sometimes in which
way miss karen is just very chaotic
she's
eccentric
wow yeah we have to knock on her door
when we come in and let her know we're
here right and sometimes she'll slam the
door in your face or
you never know what you're gonna get
really yeah i've never quite come across
and known as those right so out there
and all this stuff outside is that
fridge outside that's our um kitchen
products outside outside
yes um
this fridge here that is for the owner's
stuff they keep their food in there stop
it no look he's gonna go work oh my god
stop let me move this
seriously oh i'm scared
why is that what is that what is that i
have no idea
i don't know that is gnarly huh no
that's gnarly
so you have your own personal fridge as
well
yeah yeah outside well there's no room
inside yeah okay what's that over there
yeah this is where we store our produce
this is for the restaurant yes seriously
look at that
oh oh man i can show you the receipts
that we buy but i'm not interested in
the receipts fresh every week where are
we seasoned
touch it i don't want to touch it you
don't want to touch it but you want to
serve it karen look it's disintegrated
in my hands
more fridges down there
this way bloody how man
how old are these freezers this one's
about three years old
no
when was last time i was defrosted i
don't know bloody hell
and all this stuff stays outside yeah
jesus
a fridge
uh so that's more like a fridge
so it's a fridge we use it as a fridge
but there's more bread in here yeah uh
this is how much we need we keep running
out of stuff you do not need all this
absolutely possible what's that yes the
egg rolls egg rolls
but you're just hoarding stuff karen
i'm there
you smoke i don't know disgusting me
neither i tried when i was 17. sausage
brats
this is insane
you've never smoked cigarettes
anything else i graduate from high
school in 67 and that kind of
marijuana but i took one puff and it
made me sick and i just
[Music]
all right
um you know i was hungry but i've sort
of uh mastered your appetite let's start
off with mac and cheese okay what else
the fiesta stew okay uh let's have a
trowel as well a trout okay guys i'll
get that going right
oh back god okay here's his ticket okay
look
that's how he ordered it so mac and
cheese
are these yours yes well i bought them
taco from my store premium store okay
no wonderful i like it
so mac and cheese
thank you ma'am
the mac and cheese
that's mac and cheese that's the mac and
cheese
why's it all split on top it looks like
a soup it was in the fridge
and then they microwaved it
he's scared to eat it
that is the weirdest and the most
plastic looking mac and cheese i've ever
seen in my entire life there's no
seasoning in there there's no salt in
please
absolutely i deserve to be put under the
bed
mac and cheese he said it needs to be
put under the bed no
there you go
thank you
now we're off to fiesta stew fiesta stew
so we have a
mexican themed stew correct
and um when was the fiesta stew made
i can go ask please
hey jill when was the fiesta stew made
what's the date on it let me check
11-1
okay
[Music]
november 1st
and today today's the today's the sixth
yes
so nothing's ever fresh
never
that's terrible do you want some hot
sauce no no okay okay okay yeah i'll
move on to the next course i'm going to
take that away okay
when was this a cot
yesterday a quarter-mile yeah yeah yeah
all right trout
and jeff said he caught it yesterday so
he caught it from the frozen food
section correct
wow
it's just watery how sad is that
okay yeah
that's a disaster disaster all right
disaster trout it's disaster trout
what's wrong with it it's watery and he
knows it wasn't caught yesterday or
today
so what are you doing putting labels um
magnet labels what do not eat
no
i'm putting ice cream you're putting
labels on the freezer to tell the
muppets in the kitchen that that's ice
cream in that container kieran had asked
me to do it and when you work here at
miss sarah do you get paid are you on
the phone no i'm not on the pizza or
volunteer i visit a lot because i'm
semi-retired right now also this is my
mini bio
wow blood drives i run blood drives
every two months right
wikipedia editor mm-hmm i've done that
wow you write art travel tutor across
you teach greek i do inspire a loyalty
you're a busy lady yes sir and then um
and then i run circles around naughty
problems
i run circles around naughty problems
yeah like well if there's something that
needs to be figured out i try and figure
out a way to solve this how about a big
circle around karen i try to do that
i manage to quit look at the labels and
any other any other labels sure
cheesecake
just things
chicken breasts guacamole veggie burgers
tortillas and you just stick them on the
side of the freezer yes let me tell you
what you should be making a sign
that's the only thing should go on there
do not enter
that's brutal
can you put that on a magnet and stick
that on each freezer and one on miss
karen's fridge as well thank you
[ __ ] me
[Music]
the town's inn is much worse than i
expected the owner not only has a
hauling problem with her clothes but
she's doing the same with her food
[Music]
um le mans yes sir
why are you taking these
uh she wanted me to remove these until
she can
i only took out one bag my wardrobe
where's the rest of them from oh i have
no idea no i just noticed she had
clothes upstairs and she asked me to
move
lamont
seriously
come get her for me please [ __ ] holy
[ __ ]
i mean
he said he won't talk to you okay
miss karen yes this is is this all yours
that's what came from the wardrobe
another wardrobe no no the one that you
empty
no i had one bag full of stuff no this
is the stuff that was in the black
wardrobe in your room
but where's this stuff going now to his
basement until i can sort it out
basement
because i don't have any place to store
it here what is it it's my clothes
the things that came out of the black
wardrobe that we keep locked up in the
potomac room
do you ever ask yourself if you have a
problem holding on to things
have you ever heard of the word hoarder
miss karen
this is your business
this is your hotel not your junk shop
mm-hmm can you get the team out from the
kitchen i'd like to have a quick word of
you all in the terrace yes sir good luck
with that stuff yes yeah yeah miss
carrick we meet the team and the terrace
one two three four five six six bags
you want to check the things for bugs as
well
[Music]
i'm in shock
are you joining us with sarah are you
still writing labels no i'm not reading
later no let's go
i arrive the facade of the outside looks
beautiful i walk through the door and
it's just like a cluster of [ __ ]
crap everywhere
moldy bread and reception freaky dolls
up to the bedrooms that's like just
hideous wardrobes packed with clothes
from 30 years ago and i had to ask miss
karen to get rid of the padlock so i can
open up the wardrobe
and put my clothes in there
honestly the place is just ridden with
with this it's like a horde is anonymous
obviously i needed a place to put my
clothes and so that was where i
i put them you can't just hiven off a
wardrobe because it's full of your crap
like i said i've um
it's just a storage area no but it's not
a storage area just like your fridge
downstairs this place is played with
junk on top of junk
freezers
overbearing over full and as for the
disgusting way that the fridge is kept
with the moldy salad
there's salad that's festered and it's
like it's almost sort of disintegrated
in the center rotten
can i just quickly go on the size of the
menu it's too big the kitchen's about as
big as my wardrobe it's too it's but why
are you telling me that when the owner's
standing next to me i told her yeah but
we we have told her she won't listen
mac and cheese all separated every mouth
was full of grease because it was so
cooked in the microwave
and that's the way we do it
people say that we we've got the best
food in town in the freshers stop there
now you're sounding slightly bizarre the
best food in town
are you okay
well it depends on how you define okay
i'm okay if i'm sure by my standard but
mac and cheese i mean come on
you know
what what are you looking for now are
you taking notes yeah
you're taking notes yeah you're making
some good points
and you're laughing
what's so funny then help me to
understand
i don't have anything to do with the
food
so i don't know what you're doing i've
got no idea what you're doing
what i ask her to basically
so she does what you say she helps me
yeah
jeff is this correct
i tell him to do one thing hey sarah
tell him the way miss sarah tells you
what she just and she said she's a
volunteer she tells my crew what to do
and it pissed me off i get i get mad
then they blame it on me she's got the
authority to do that i know jeff you've
never talked to me about this
i have told you
i have told you about this
is this is this true this is where you
treat the staff nothing more humiliating
to the team that are on the ground
keeping this place open and then a
stranger comes in and tells them what to
do
well she's not a stranger she's been
coming to them she is because she's not
exactly qualified to run this place
this is so screwed up this is bizarre
ain't nobody hearing me what i'm saying
i'm what kind of message you're sending
the menu needs to be down a menu like
this there must be 50 items on there
which 49 of them are turfed out of the
bloody freezer
this place is so messed up
it's a mess a disgusting
festering mess well you ain't seeing
nothing yet
unbelievable
i don't know i'm just so [ __ ]
embarrassed
i know
[Music]
[Music]
so far i've learned that not only does
karen hoard items but she's also a
controlling owner
tonight i want to see how the towns inn
operates during the evening how are you
good and your name is my name is tyler
tyler what'd you do um i'm a server okay
great tyler and hello hi i'm gage gage
what are you two doing out here we are
both servers come in so i can talk to
you where's the best place to hang this
i can hang it for you sir i mean no you
didn't have these filthy hats laying
around i know why do you have filthy
hats in the hallway looks like so it
looks like a thrift shop soon first job
how old are you guys i am 17 i'm also
17. 17. objectively what's wrong with
this place well i think that we're not
well organized i also think that we need
to work on cleanliness cleanliness yes
wow is it that bad it can be uh so what
do you think's dirty well uh honestly
probably the kitchen and uh someone why
are you going into the house
what what you asked what was dirty so i
mean common things that we try to clean
every day that we can't always keep an
eye on show me where the kitchen is
please yeah okay thank you
what happened here sarah likes to paint
on the walls
hello hi what's this mess here this is a
painting and i do what
a painting it looks like someone shat
all over the wall
is that hygienic you're painting the
walls of the kitchen i have no idea
so why did you do it
the town's in became sarah's town's inn
even though she had nothing to do with
owning the establishment
did you see the mess in the kitchen
she's painting the wall
let me show you something right here
yeah yeah yeah have you seen it yes
it's one of my favorite things it's one
of your favorite things no seriously
i'm live maybe not well
did you see the mural in the dining room
that is a children assist in guests
that's unique isn't it what is that well
it started as a crack in the wall and i
asked sarah to make a vine is that
anywhere else you've painted there is a
uh
in my room you show me please
what have you done to my wall
this is so weird you paint over cracks
look at this here i know and this
apparently is something new that is
falling apart
wow i mean it must be wet
wet it's soaking wet the plaster's just
whoa
these are bits of card that's correct it
was a temporary fix so it's not a mural
there's business cards you put your
cards on here and then you paint over
the cards
you should make a label for this
decaying wall do not paint over it i
mean
what
the wall's rotten
and you just go and paint over it it was
meant as a temporary thing wool is
you're right and you just paint over it
you can't just go fill in cracks with
tacky painting look at it down here
you've gone over cracks and holes look
jesus
what's that in there um i put some sort
of a mesh because it was
a hole and i didn't want anything to
come through it
jesus
i wish you wouldn't use that word what
hole
what'd you really sing [ __ ]
hallelujah that'd be better
can you get me karen i can get me
carrying please
jesus what's your language sir
what the [ __ ]
miss karen oh my goodness well the whole
thing just started coming off the wall
needs repairing and she's just painting
over it and then secondly she found a
big hole here
started putting the cards on there and
then painted over that
but inside the hole oh jesus
this is not a paper mache
what is she doing to your hotel it
doesn't go outside i mean it's not a
hole to the outside
it's not a hole it's outside no what
does that mean the stone wall is out
there oh we're sleeping on the inside
we're not sleeping on the outside right
so you're not going to get any cold
drafts or anything through there so just
like i don't get to use the wardrobe
with the holes on the inside not on the
outside and we can just do whatever we
want what if she's stuffing
it's really solid it needs to master it
we can't just paint over that well you
can
we did and then stick brillo pads in the
hole
you can't just band-aid this place
oh my goodness just wash my hands
order french bread as an app all right
um what is that their sports bar are
these tv screens what are those
microwaves how many microwaves have you
got well there's four here and one in
there that's five
microwaves there's one in there and two
chefs two chefs
oh my god
everywhere a turn there's just junk
everywhere well this is cooking stuff
trust me i know what cooking stuff this
is not cooking that's not okay
how does this kitchen function give me a
little tour very challenging very very
challenging what's up man that's a
burger that i'm heating up
a boil yeah
you're boiling a burger i'm just heating
it back up when you say heating it back
up why aren't you cooking it from fresh
we make them ahead of time this is what
we got here we don't a boiled burger
are you where the burgers are boiled um
no
do you think a customer would want a
burger boiled in water they seem to like
them just taste the water oh do i have
to i would say
you won't taste it okay well i just
tastes like water with beef in it that
seems okay
when they fix it up on a nice kaiser
road with lettuce tomato onions
i need a tom please
i need a separate ah clear
[ __ ]
no this is a joke this is
terrible i'm a pool to learn that the
town's in boils pre-cooked burgers
brendan
well just show me the table with a bow
and what's more frustrating is how karen
doesn't think there is anything wrong
with that
come with me two seconds i'll quickly
show you something
perfect
absolutely so that's your burger out of
respect as a customer uh i'm not gonna
sit and watch with that [ __ ]
let me show you
so
this is the chef yes you just explained
how you cooked that were you pre-cooking
don't start from the top please i'm not
gonna let you eat that we um pre-cook
them you made the burger when
um jill when we're done burgers mate
yesterday i believe yesterday
just explain how you reheated them for
the gentleman i'll be here them i put i
put water in there and i put the burger
in there
were you expecting a fresh burger or
some [ __ ]
something fresh i will give you a fresh
burger my apologies thank you i'm sorry
sir
okay
this ticket refused their food okay
young man
add respect for our guests let's take
the ladies outside and show whether we
keep the freezers again ladies and
gentlemen just bear with us for two
minutes but we're just gonna show you
something i'd like you to see yes so
just follow me this is just right down
here
watcher out here yes um right here next
to the trash yes
um this is our lasagna
this is our trout we got more sausage
ice cream these are your ankles right
there
yes yes ma'am yes ma'am
we've got two freezers and everything's
scattered very cluttered i mean karen
has always uh looked at this as her home
obviously it is embarrassing but it's a
serious situation that needs to be
solved you okay
yeah
i'm sorry
yeah it's okay
but i think i just canceled my order my
apologies now i discovered that today
and i out of respect for you as
customers i can't sit here and fake you
eating that [ __ ] so i'm hoping that you
can skip around the menu and order
something a little bit more
thank you keeping my apologies thank you
thank you so much didn't you have purple
glasses earlier yeah yeah
oh that is so cool because they look
like they're dark brown or black oh yeah
they're like black that is so cool this
is insane yeah sarah claims to work at
the town zone here's a free postcard for
everybody when i go to serve tables
she'll randomly show up we'll talk to
tables um i've seen her frustrate
people sarah
is someone calling me i have to go
yes sir
they don't need to hear your life story
they want to sit and have a romantic
drink on the terrace
leave them alone okay i'm with you in
and out there are other tables
okay we're gonna need a rotisserie
chicken i believe that's rotisserie
chicken you get it from the freezer
disgusting
just playing the rotisserie chicken
please show the table yeah this is the
dish of the day it's our rotisserie
chicken
it was roasted six months ago in a
grocery store and we're serving it for
twelve dollars
on the menu it's got rotisserie chicken
yeah
buy them at a grocery store yes and you
freeze them
and you reheat them in the microwave not
in the microwave it went in the
microwave
what is going on here
well we have
a menu and
we just do it i mean no this is pathetic
how many of your guests tonight think
that their chicken's been roasted
in-house maybe half let's just let me
come in let's double check
ladies and gentlemen so sorry i could
just have your attention for 30 seconds
how many of you if you're gonna order
the roast chicken this evening would
expect it to be
fresh roasted in-house could you raise
your hands please
i think it's everybody
[Music]
a lot of people say it's it's good i
agree that it's uh
these guests have come out of their
homes to come and eat what i'm not gonna
do is attempt to pull the wool over
their eyes because they deserve to know
what's going on the burgers were cooked
yesterday and reheated in a pan boiling
them in water and i'm flabbergasted so
you need to take a real good look at
yourself and stop bullshitting customers
immediately otherwise i'm out of here
i'm so sorry but you as customers
deserve better and there's nothing to do
with the tv program i promise you now
it's based on the bad practices that's
going on in that kitchen so my apologies
but i'm not gonna allow you to eat
you're not gonna act responsible for it
i will
we're shutting it down
we're shutting it down
he just sent everybody home stop
stop
that
is possibly the worst thing i've seen so
far
how do you reheat that
in the microwave in the microwave
it doesn't even hit an oven but we used
to cook them fresh right
so what what changed i was in here yeah
so what happened stop i'm not serving it
stop what happened
ask karen
i ain't the one that bought the chickens
i have about to have a rotisserie thing
back here i can have fried chicken we
need new equipment this is what it's
resulted in this is what we're serving
you can't buy this from a grocery store
no you can't sprinkle it pasta and
expect to call yourselves a restaurant i
know which is i know what you're saying
and you just like a butterfly fly around
just painting all little bits of [ __ ]
over holes this is insane i'm done i'm
i'm upset
i'm i'm feeling sick and i've never seen
such a disgusting mess in all my [ __ ]
life it's embarrassment to you you you
and me
and i'm not gonna stand there and watch
you serve [ __ ] like that and take
customers money what is this
i eat them often the rotisserie you eat
them often
what does that say
i guess it just that i don't
what does that mean to you you eat this
crap often
come on
you're running a hotel
the burgers were cooked yesterday
well when i ate them and i always tell
them they tasted good to me
where's the burgers that you cooked down
here so get them
my understanding you see pat in the
mouth and then put them in the oven how
long for for about 15 20 minutes 15 20
minutes in another
how many your customers expect burgers
to be cooked like that baked in the oven
for 20 minutes so there's no color on
there cooled down stuck in a zip locker
bag out bowling water should we go and
do another survey what's eighty percent
chuck it's just your hamburger you are
seriously in denial
miss sarah would you like a bite no
thank you why not it's not cooked right
or should i boil it up for you get it
warm
what color is that
it's white
that's what frustrates me we're all
pretending that this is good
i thought that's what the cooks know i
mean
come on no i mean i'm not trying to
blame it on the cooks you can't blame it
on me because ain't nobody hearing me
i'm amazed you're not shut down
frieza's lined up next to a dumpster
what lives outside in those passageways
next to dumpsters bat rats now bats rats
and mice
you are in denial
you have a big problem
you've got no idea that this place is
crumbling
and you're just going through the
motions
mr ramsay my guests want to leave
your guests want to leave
that's the best thing i've heard all day
can i [ __ ] join them
are we serving food at all should i
leave and we're in danger i've even been
shut down by the health authorities and
there is no [ __ ] way i'm going to
stand there and watch this [ __ ] being
reheated and served so sorry
we're not moving forward
you